[موسيقى]
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
اوكرانيا تتوقعه هجوم روسيا هذا الشهر
وتتعهد بعدم الضرب الاراضي الروسيه
بالصواريخ بعيده المدى
في مرمى نيران الجمهوريين بسبب المنطاد
الصيني وسكينه تتخذ خطوه استباقيه وتقيل
مدير هيئه الارصاد
العربيه في معسكر النسائي للتشمرجا تعرض
شهادات حصريه من متظاهرات هربنا من
التعذيب في ايران البقاء في ايران بعد ان
شاركنا في مظاهرات وتعرضنا للتهديد ربما
حتى للاعتداء من قبل الامن الايراني
فانتقلنا الى هنا الى كردستان
الكشف عن اربع ثغرات اساسيه في برنامج
تشارت الذي يستخدم تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
وصلتم اوقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
فيما تقترب من اتمام عامها الاول بات
ميدان العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
رهن تقدم روسي في الشرق وحرب شوارع في
ضخمه حيث يحاول الجيش الروسي بسط السيطره
الكامله على المناطق الاوكرانيه وفي
المقابل تقوم قوتك روسيا بدعم عسكري
ولوجستي من القوى الغربيه حيث تتوقع هجوم
الروسيا واسعا هذا الشهر في اخر التطورات
مشاهدينا افادت قوته فاجنر بانها باتت
تحاصر مدينه باخموت من الناحيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه لتصل الى اطراف مدينه قسطنطين
وتسيطر على الطريق السريع الذي يوصل
الامدادات العسكريه من
فيما تدور معارك داريا في ايفانوفكا
باطراف ضخمه وفي نفس المحور الجنوبي بحسب
قائد قوات باجنر دائما بينما تتقدم القوات
الروسيه من المحور الشمالي بضواحي ضخمه
وتحاول السيطره على بلدات اضافيه وتتقدم
نحو سيفرسك عبر سوليدار
وفي ظل التطورات الميدانيه التي تشهدها
ساحه الحرب في اوكرانيا جرد الرئيس
الاوكراني
العديد من السياسيين ذوي النقود السابقين
سلبهم او جردهم من الجنسيه في احدث خطوات
لتطهير البلاد من التيارات المؤثره
المواليه لروسيا فيما ذكرت وسائل الاعلام
الحكوميه الاوكرانيه ان القائمه تضم
العديد من
مكتب فيكتور كما شملت وزير التعليم
والعلوم السابق ونائب رئيس الوزراء السابق
بالاضافه الى وزير الداخليه السابقه ايضا
سحب الجنسيه من سياسيين سابقين
بامر من الرئيس الاوكراني
والسبب تطهير البلاد من الموالين لروسيا
وسائل اعلام حكوميه نشرت الاسماء
من بينهم
ديمتري تاب تشينج وزير التعليم والعلوم
السابق متهمون بالخيانه العظمى لصالح
روسيا
كلوب السكرتيرو السابق لمجلس الامن القومي
لاوكرانيا متهم بارتكابه جرائم قتل جماعي
لنشطاء اوكرانيين
فيتاليزا خارجينكو وزير الداخليه السابق
لاوكرانيا حاصل على الجنسيه الروسيه
الكسندر يا كيمينكو الرئيس السابق لجهاز
الامن في اوكرانيا متهم بارتكابه مذابح
بحق نشطاء اوكرانيين
الكسندر كليمنكو الوزير السابق للدخل
والرسوم متهم بارتكاب عدد من الاجراءات
الجنائيه
هذا واتعهد وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيكوف بعدم استهداف روسيا
بالصواريخ طويله المدى واكدا انهم سيضربون
فقط الوحدات الروسيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه تعهد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ياتي بعد ان اكدت الولايات المتحده في وقت
سابق ان صاروخ جديدا بعيدا المدى يمكنه ان
يضاعف مدى الهجمات الاوكرانيه وهو مدرج
ضمن حزمه المساعدات عسكريه امريكيه بقيمه
2.2 مليار دولار
لمساعدتكييف على مقاومه القوات الروسيه
ربما قراتم بالفعل ان شركائنا الامريكيين
قرروا يوم الجمعه تزويدنا باسلحه قادره
على اطلاق النار على مسافه 150 كيلومترا
نقول دائما لشركائنا اننا نلتزم بعدم
استخدام الاسلحه المقدمه من الشركاء
الاجانب ضد اراضي روسيا ولكن فقط ضد
وحداتها في الاراضي المحتله مؤقتا في
اوكرانيا
نتابع مع مراسلنا في دنيتك رائد الاغبر
رائد اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه اذا
تقدم الروسي في الشرق وحرب شوارع في باخمت
هلا اجملت لنا اخر واهم التطورات العسكريه
في الحرب الاوكرانيه اليوم
مساء الخير صهيب بالفعل يعني قوات فاجنر
تطوق مدينه باقمت من جميع النواحي
الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه كما انها
توسع الطوق من الناحيتين الشماليه الغربيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه وتتقدم كما اسلفت بحرب
شوارع في اطراف المدينه من نواحي مختلفه
في بلده ايفانا من ناحيه الجنوبيه كما ان
مصانع اللحوم من الناحيه الشرقيه ايضا
تقاتل فيها القوات الخاصه الروسيه وتتقدم
وتسيطر على بعض الاراضي الناحيه الشماليه
تشهد تطورات كبيره ايضا حيث انها تتقدم
نحو عده بلدات وتقول يعني المصادر من هناك
بان الطوق اصبح قريبا جدا من الاكتمال
والقوات الروسيه الاله العسكريه ثقيله
تقصف طرق التي توصل الامدادات طريقين من
شسوبيار ومن قسنطينه تحت مرمى نيران
المدافع الصواريخ الروسيه ايضا باتت يعني
الطريق الاهم وهي الطريق بين باقي متوشه
سوبيار قريبه على بعد كيلو متر واحد من
اقتراب قوات بازنار اليها حيث دخلوا الى
بلده في ذلك المحور تبعت كيلو متر واحد
كان هناك خبر نقلته طاس قبل قليل رائد لا
لم اذا كانت هناك المزيد من المعطيات
الدفاع الروسيه قالت بان نظام كيابي يخطط
لتفجير المباني الطبيه في كراماتورسك في
دنيتك هل هناك اي معلومات اضافيه حول هذا
البيان من الدفاع الروسيه
حقيقه ليس لدينا اي معلومات لكن بالفعل
هناك عده حالات كانت مماثله حيث في مريوبل
كان هناك مختبرات كيميائيه كبيره قامت
القوات الاوكرانيه قبل دخول ماريوبل
بتفجير المختبرات واتهمت روسيا ان هذه
المختبرات هي مختبرات بيولوجيه تحضر الى
جراثيم وقنابل جرثوميه ربما يكون اتهام
وزاره الدفاع مماثل لما حصل
شكرا لك رائد وهذا خبر عاجل الان اذا نقل
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني من منصبه الى منصب
وزاريا اخر مشاهدينا الخبر العاجل
تشاهدونه على الشاشه نذكر بان وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني كان قال سابقا انه لا يستقيل
الا اذا قرر الرئيس الاوكراني نقله من
منصبه او ازالته ابعاده عن منصبه الان
رويتر ستنقل بانه جرى نقل وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني من منصبه الى منصب وزاري اخر
سنوافيكم
المزيد من التفاصيل حول ورودها فيما يتعلق
بهذا التطور السياسي في اوكرانيا
كشفت صحيفه ان
اصل على تزويد الرو
س بهذه الحرب من تكنولوجيات متطوره
موسكو تزود مقاتلاتها وغواصاتها وجنودها
بمختلف الحاجيات بمساعدات الشركات الصينيه
صحيفه
قالت ان العمليه تتم من خلال تعويض جوانب
النقص او الخلل من التكنولوجيا ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج كاشباه الموصلات وهو
امر ضروري للحرب الحديثه اذ تمد الصين
روسيا بمعدات الملاحه والتشويش واجزاء
الطائرات المقاتله حيث قامت شركه صينيه
مملوكه للدوله بشحن قطع غيار للمقاتلات 35
النفاثه الى شركه روسيه مملوكه للحكومه
خاضعه للعقوبات بما قيمته مليار ومئتين
مليون دولار فلوسيا ما تزال قادره على
استيراد تكنولوجيا رقائق الكمبيوتر
وكاميرات الاشعه تحت الحمراء ومعدات
الرادار من خلال دول لم تنضم الى الجهود
التي تقودها الولايات المتحده لعزل عن
الاسواق العالميه كتركيا وفق اول ستريت
جورنال الصحيفه حددت من السجلات اكثر من
12 شركه روسيه وصينيه استهدفتها الولايات
المتحده في اطار حمله الضغط على روسيا
بالاضافه الى جميع برامج العقوبات الاخرى
وقبل بدايه الحرب العام الماضي اعلن
بوتينغ شراكه بلا حدود بعد ذلك حاولت بكين
تحقيق توازن حذر قائله انها تعارض الحرب
مع ابقاء علاقاتها الدبلوماسيه والماليه
والتجاريه مفتوحه مع روسيا بلال البشتين
العربيه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا عاطفا على العاجل السابق
المتعلق بنقل وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الى
منصب وزاري اخر الان رويترز تفيد ايضا
بانه جرت تعيين مدير المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في منصب وزير الدفاع لتذكير
فان هناك سلسله من الاقالات
والمتابعه القضائيه كذلك بحق مسؤولين
اوكرانيين نافذين بتهم فساد فيما اطلقت
عليه السلطات الاوكرانيه اسم العدو
الداخلي اي تقصد محاربه الفساد في
اوكرانيا اق السلطات الصينيه رئيس هيئه
الارصاد الجويه في البلاد وحملته مسؤوليه
انحراف المنطاد الى الولايات المتحده ياتي
ذلك في متاهم مسؤولون في الصين بامتلاكها
اسطولا من مناطيد المراقبه والتجسس في
سماء خمس قارات مضيفا ان المنطاد لم يكن
مرتبطا بالارصاد الجويه بل ارادت الصين
استخدامه للتجسس على مواقع عسكريه حساسه
[موسيقى]
وتفاصيل منطاد التجسس الصيني الذي شغل
الولايات المتحده والعالم سقط بصاروخ واحد
بعد ان تجول لايام في الاجواء الامريكيه
هذا المنطاد بدا مساره فوق جزر الاسكا ثم
اتجه نحو كندا لاحلق بعيدا ويدخل المجال
الجوي الامريكي فوق ولايه مونتانا في
الحادي والثلاثين من يناير الاسبوع الماضي
المنطاد عاده هو عباره عن سفينه هوائيه
تملا بغاز هيدروجين او هيليوم ويمكن ان
يرتفع في الجو من دون جهاز دفع ويحمل
باسفله جهاز التجسس او غيره حسب طبيعه
المهمه التي يقوم بها اما المنطاد الصيني
الذي تم رصده في الاجواء الامريكيه فيصعب
اسقاطه من مضادات الطائرات لان معظم انظمه
الاسلحه المضاده لطائرات الامريكيه لم تكن
مصممه للقضاء على الاهداف المرتفعه ولاجل
ذلك لجات واشنطن لاسقاطه بمقاتله من طراز
اف 22 واطلقت عليه صاروخا واحدا من طراز
اي اي ام 9 اكس هذا الصاروخ هو صاروخ جو
جو قصير المدى تصل كلفته الى 400 الف
دولار دخل الخدمه في البحريه الامريكيه
عام 66 واستخدمته القوات الجويه عام 64
الجيش الامريكي يعمل حاليا على استعاده
حموله المنطاد الذي اسقط على بعد سته
اميال بحريه قباله السواحل الولايات
المتحده وعلى عمق 47 قدما وهو ما يسهل من
عمليه جمعها عبر غواصين ومركبه غير ماهوله
لانتشال جسم البالون ورفعه لسطح الماء الى
سفينه الانتشال بهدف التحقيق فيماهيه مهمه
المنطاد الصيني هذا والجزم فيها وفقا
لشبكه سي ان ام
معنى من بكين دينجل استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه شنغهاي مرحبا بكم معنا
استاذ دينك كولومبيا ايضا اعلنت انها رصدت
منطادا ثانيا يحلق في اجوائها بعد تحذير
الولايات المتحده بان هناك منطاد صينيا
يحلق في امريكا اللاتينيه هل هذا المنطاد
الثاني ايضا للارصاد الجويه وانحرف على
المساره
اعتقد ان وفقا
لتصريحات
خارجيه الصينيه انها
تستخدم للاهداف البحثيه خصوصا الاقتصاد
الجويه
ويعني
يعترفت السن
ملكيه
من ت لكن
الولايات المتحده تتحم وتزعم مع ان هذه
المنطاد هو للتجسس
نعم ولكن
لماذا ما هي الاسباب الحقيقيه وراء اقاله
الصين رغم نفيها ان هذا البالون يعني هو
للتجسس لماذا قالت مدير هيئه الارصاد
الجويه
لانه
دخل
مجال جوي الامريكي ان الخطا بدون قصد وفقا
وبيانات
الصينيه لكن هناك اختلافات واختلافات
كبيره
بينما مقولتين المقوله الامريك
الصينيه
فنحتاج الى وهذا الخلاف في الروايتين
الامريكيه والصينيه يعني حتى رغم اقاله
مدير هيئه الارصاد الجويه الصينيه
الامريكيون ما زالوا متشبثين بان هذا
البالون هو بالون تجسس صيني وليس موجود في
امريكا فقط بل هو موجود في مناطق اخرى
كذلك من العالم كيف ترون كذلك التشبث
الامريكي بهذه الروايه روايه ان المنطاد
هو لغايه التجسس وليس للارصاد الجويه كما
تقول الصين
خلينا ننتظر
البراهين والادله
تحقيق يعني تحقيقه يعني انا الطرفين
القيام
بهزار دلائل
وابراهيم للتاكيد على
هويه
واغراض
وظائف نعم نعم سيد لونج وزاره الدفاع
الصينيه يعني كانت يعني
اوردت عباره لافته الحقيقه قالت ان الصين
تحتفظ بحق الرد على الولايات المتحده
بالوسائل اللازمه في حال ظهور حادث شبيه
بمنطاد الارصاد الجويه الصيني مع سهى يكون
طبيعه الرد المختلف اذا ما تكررت الحادثه
لان
الولايات المتحده
اكبر دوله تجسس في العالم هي تقوم يعني
بشكل يومي
عمليه بعمليات تجسس في الصين
وفي في العالم
واخذتها مع طول
حلفاء نعم فيعني كل يوم
تقوم الولايات المتحده
بالتجسد على الصين
نعم ولذلك لان الولايات المتحده عاده هي
ما تقوم بهذه الانشطه ولكن الان الصين
تقدمت في هذا المجال كما تقول الولايات
المتحده طبعا هناك من يرى اننا دخلنا
مرحله الحرب البارده الصينيه الامريكيه هل
توافق ان حادثه المنطاد هي بدايه الحرب
البارده الصينيه الامريكيه
لا اعتقد ذلك لان
انشد تجسس
شيء يعني عادي
وكثير بين دول العالم خصوصا بين طول
الكبرى وهذا شيء يعني عادي جدا
وهو لا يدل على ان العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه تخلط
الحرب البارده
واعتقد ان هناك لا تزال
لتحسين العلاقات بينهما جميل شكرا جزيلا
لكم كنتم معنا
في جامعه شنغهاي
هذا وعبر رئيس لجنه القوات المسلحه بمجلس
النواب الامريكيه النائب
الجمهوريز عن قلقه من قرار اداره الرئيس
جو بايدن بالسماحل لمنضاد التجسس الصيني
بعبور الولايات المتحده واتهم روجرز اداره
الامريكيه بانها كانت تامل في اخفاء فشل
الامن القومي هذا عن الكونغرس والشعب
الامريكي واعتبر روجرز انه يجب على البيت
الابيض تقديم اجابات بشان الضرر الذي لحق
بالامن القومي من هذا القرار مؤكدا انه
يجب على الولايات المتحده ان تظهر قوتها
لردع الصين وان هذا الفشل مثال اخر على
ضعف اداره بايدن
[موسيقى]
انتقد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بحده منافسيها المحتملين للفوز
ببطاقه الحزب الجمهوري للانتخابات
الرئاسيه لعام 2014
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب يهاجم كل من
يفكر بالترشح ضده
بدا بوصف نكهه هيلي مندوبه امريكا لدى
الامم المتحده سابقا
نيكي تعاني من امر صعب جدا فهي طموحه
للغايه
حتى من لم يعلن بعد ترشحها ما حكم ولايتي
فلوريدا فيرجينيا طالتهما سهام ترامب الذي
اتهمهما بانهما نكراني للجميل
مايك بنس نائب ترامب السابق واجه مهاجمه
مباشره منه يعزو الفضه لنفسه فيما وصل له
بنت
لقد ساعدت كل هؤلاء الاشخاص انا من اخرجت
مايك بنس من العدم
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع السعوديه انطلاق
مناورات التمرين الجويه المختلط رماح
النصر 2023 في نسختها الثالثه بمركز الحرب
الجوي بالقطاع الشرقي بمشاركه ثمان دول
ويهدف التمرين الذي تنفذه القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه الى تعزيز مفهوم العمل
المشترك ورفع مستوى الاداء والجاهزيه
القتاليه للوحدات المشاركه ويشهد التمرين
مشاركه دوليه واسعه تمثلت في البحرين
الاردن باكستان قطر اليونان المملكه
المتحده والولايات المتحده اضافه الى ثلاث
دول ملاحظه وهي الامارات والكويت وسلطنه
عمان
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه خامنئي يعفو عن
العديد من السجناء ومنظمه حقوق الانسان
بايران تعتبره مجرد دعايه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في ايران باتل الشعب
الواقع تحت سياسه نظام قمعي لسنوات كلمه
ترجمتها الاحتجاجات الاخيره التي شهدتها
البلاد اما كرسي يخامنئي فلم يعد صلبا في
الاصوات التي علت في شوارع ايران احتجاجا
على العنف والقمع دفعته لاصدار عفو عن
عشرات الالاف من السجناء ومن العديد من
المعتقلين في الاحتجاجات الاخيره فيما
افادت وسائل الاعلام الرسميه بانه سيتم
العفو عن السجناء الذين لا يواجهون
اتهامات بالتجسس لصالح جهه اجنبيه او
بوجود صله مباشره تربطهم بعملاء في الخارج
او بتعمد القتل او التسبب في الاصابه او
بالتسبب في دمار واحراق ممتلكات الدوله او
من لا يوجد مدعي خاص في قضاياهم لكن بعد
وقت قصير من اعلان الافراج هذا عن الاف
المعتقلين افادت وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه
بان السلطات اعتقلت الصحفيه اليناز
المحمدي والتي تعمل في احدى المؤسسات
الاعلاميه التابعه للاصلاحيين دون توضيح
سبب الاعتقال كما اصدر القضاء عقوبه السجن
سنه واحده بحق الصحفي حسين يسدي الموقوف
في اصفهان لتصل قائمه الصحفيين المعتقلين
على خلفيه الاحتجاجات في ايران الى ثلاثين
صحفيا هذا وجه الرئيس الايراني الاسبق
محمد خاتمي رساله بمناسبه الذكرى الرابعه
والاربعين لثوره الخميني وحث المرشد علي
خامنئي على ضروره الانصياع لتوقعات ورغبات
الشعب والنظر الى مصالح الاجيال القادمه
خاتمي اضاف ان الاصلاح الذي اعتمده النظام
يمكن القول انه فشل او وصل الى طريق مسدود
على حد تعبيره معتبرا انه من حق الشعب ان
يخيب امله من هذا الاصلاح كما خاب امله من
النظام الحاكم نفسه
وفي سياق متصل دعامير الحسين موسوي
القياديه الايراني والمعارض والمعتقل منذ
فتره طويله دعا الى استفتاء عام حول كتابه
دستور جديد لايران وسط احتجاجات عارمه على
مستوى البلاد كما دعى موسوي الى تشكيل
جمعيه دستوريه من ممثلين حقيقيين لكتابه
الدستور
هذا ووصف مدير منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه محمود اميري وصف القرار الذي
اصدره المرشد الايراني علي خامنائي بالعفو
عن معتقل الاحتجاجات وصفه بالدعايه ولا
يغيروا شيئا على حد قوله ودعا مدير
المنظمه التي تتخذ من النرويج مقرا لها
الى محاسبه من امروا بالقمع الدموي على حد
وصفه بدلا من التشرق في فئات المحتجين
المفرج عنهم
[موسيقى]
وضمن تغطيتنا الخاصه للاحزاب الايرانيه
المعارضه التقت العربيه بمتظاهرات انضممنا
حديثا الى حزب الحريه الكردستاني الايراني
المعارض تركنا خلفهن عائلاتهم وقصصا
ماساويه ميديا فتاه تعرضت للاعتقال
والتعذيب بالكهرباء لتعترف بشيء لم ترتكبه
واخرى تروي قصه ابن عمها التي اغتصبها
سجنوها امام اخيها حسب ما تقول
[موسيقى]
الوجهه موقع ما على اطراف كردستان العراق
بلغنا بعنوانه قبل لحظات فقط من بدء
رحلتنا
[موسيقى]
تبين ان هذه ليست الوجهه النهائيه كان
علينا السير على الاقدام مسافه الى مكان
اخر يرفضن ذكر اي تفاصيل حوله
يقولن ان هذا لضمان امنهن فهذا معسكر هنا
الجديد
وياملنا ان يبقى سريا
[موسيقى]
لدينا قوات متمركزه في منطقه بردي على
الخطوط الاماميه كانت لدينا قوات عسكريه
نسائيه تمركزت هناك ايضا بعدها هجمات
النظام الايراني بالصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره تم نقلنا الى هذه المنطقه
المقاتلات الموجودات هنا يمثلنا ثلث
المقاتلات داخل الحزب لدينا وحدات عسكريه
للمقاتلات في موقعين اخرين تضم هذه
الوحدات اكثر من 200 مقاتله
[موسيقى]
فتاه يتبعن لحزب تحرير كردستان المعروف
اختصارا بباك احد احزاب المعارضه الكرديه
الايرانيه النشطه في الخارج
يتوزعنا على ثلاثه مواقع للتدريب
والتدريب هنا يقصد به رياضه قتاليه
والسلاح
ومحاضرات عن السياسه والحقوق
مهسى اميني التي اثار مقتلها مظاهرات في
ايران لا تزال ترهم الكثير من الفتيات
والنساء
اللواتي تؤمن بشعار المراه الحياه الحريه
بعضهن عجزنا عن البقاء في ايران بعد ان
شاركنا في مظاهرات وتعرضنا للتهديد ربما
حتى للاعتداء من قبل الامن الايراني
فانتقلنا الى هنا الى كردستان العراق
في هذا الموقع وجوه على ملامح الترقب
واخرى توشحه اللثام وهنا قصه مختلفه فتيات
كنا بالامس القريب في شوارع المدن
الايرانيه يتظاهرنا قررنا المغادره لكنهن
يخشين على عائلتهن اذا ما تعرفت عليهن
استخبارات النظام الايراني
لمشارك في فقط بل كنت قائده لها لكن لم
يعد بامكاني العيش هناك بحريه لان القوات
الايرانيه تعرفت علي وحكم علي بالسجن في
اليوم الاول الذي عدنا فيه من جنازه جينا
امين الى مدينه سننضج اجتمعنا في ميدان
اقبال كنا نردد شعارات مثل المراه الحياه
الحريه جاءت قوات النظام لتفريقنا
باستخدام الهروات واحتجزون جميعا تقريبا
واخذونا الى مقرهم تعرضت للتعذيب تضمن ذلك
الضربه والصعقه بالكهرباء وادوات اخرى
يتعاطفنا مع مهسانيني وان كنا يقلن انهن
شهدنا وسمعنا عن اخريات قصصهن توازيها او
تفوقها الى منه
احدى هذه الحالات كانت ابنه عمي تعرضت
للاغتصاب والايذاء امام شقيقها هناك
المئات من الحالات المماثله هؤلاء الناس
يفقدون الامل ينهارون ولا يمكن الاستمرار
في الحياه لقد راينا اعمالا غير انسانيه
جدا من قبل القوات الايرانيه خلال
الانتفاضه الحاليه
انتهى يوم التدريب او يكاد طبقت هذه
الجلسه اليوميه يقولن انها ضروريه ففيها
قليل من الراحه والغناء وكثير مشعرات
الثوره والمراه
صار ابن عشوب العربيه كردستان العراق
[موسيقى]
في السودان اتهمت الحركه الشعبيه التيار
الثوريه الديمقراطي ما اسمتها القوى
المضاده للثوره بالسعي الى اجهاض العمليه
السياسيه بالبلاد والتخريب الاتفاق
الايطالي والقضاء على الثوره واستعاده
النظام القديم الحركه الشعبيه بقياده ياسر
عرمان اكدت دعمها للاتفاق الايطالي مضيفه
ان هنالك قوى تعمل على المراوغه وشراء
الوقت والدفع بالقوى المضاده للثوره
لتخريب العمليه السياسيه واشددت الحركه
على ضروره عمل قوى الحريه والتغيير على
تعزيز العمل الجماهيري
[موسيقى]
سودانيه ايضا قال عضو مجلس السياده
السوداني شمس الدين كباشي في زيارته
لولايه جنوب كردفان ان القوات الموقعه
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي ليست كافيه
لتحقيق الاستقرار في السودان معتبرا ان
على المواقعين ان يقبلوا الاخرين لتوسيع
قاعده المشاركه
لطائر القوى اللي وقعت عليه وليست كافي
احنا ادنى معقول ومقبول
لتحقيق الاستقرار السياسي والاستقرار في
كافه لانه كل بينحجز على الامن وعلى
الاقتصاد وغيره وغير
انه احنا ندعو كل الاخوه
الموقعين على الاتفاق الاداري انه يفتحوا
صدورهم ويقبلوا الاخرين
صحيح ما ممكن ما كل الناس
لكن بيبقى برضو الدفاع متوافق عليه
بيتدرجه مقبوله من الناس لانه ما في توافق
كامل
[موسيقى]
نعود بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه ونتابع
تويتر تفرض رسوما باهضه مقابل علامه
التوثيق الذهبيه للشركات
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قله الوكاله الوطنيه
للامن السيبراني في ايطاليا ان الالاف من
خوادم الكمبيوتر في جميع انحاء العالم
استهدفت بهجوم قرصنه من برمجيات الفديه
واكدت الوكاله ان هجوم القرصنه سعى الى
استغلال ثغره في البرمجيات مضيفا انه كان
على نطاق واسع واخترق الخوادم في دول
اوروبيه اخرى مثل فرنسا وفنلندا وكذلك
الولايات المتحده وكندا وادعت وكاله الامن
السيبراني في ايطاليا المنظمات المحليه
الى اتخاذ اجراءات لحمايه انظمتها
[موسيقى]
قرارات شركه العملاق الازرق لا تتوقف وبات
الطائر يحلق بين اجراءات داخليه واخرى
خارجيه لجني الاموال تقريرنا نشره موقع ذي
انفورميشن افاد بان تويتر تريد جني
الاموال من الشركات على المنصه وذلك من
خلال فرض رسوم قدرها 1000 دولار امريكي
شهريا للاحتفاظ بعلامه التوثيق الذهبيه
ووفقا للتقرير فان العلامات التجاريه التي
لا تدفع الرسوم الشهريه ستفقد علامه
التوثيق الذهبيه هذه ومع ذلك فانه من غير
الواضح متى سيحدث ذلك وتكشف الرسائل
الداخليه التي اطلعها اطلع عليها موقع
دينفورميشن ان تويتر ستفرض رسوما اضافيه
قدرها 50 دولارا شهريا لاضافه علامات
التوثيق الى كل حساب تابع لشركه
[موسيقى]
ومن تويتر الى منصه المحادثه الجديده التي
تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتي اطلقتها شركه اوبن اي اي اواخر
العام الماضي المنصه اصبحت موضوع الحديث
الاول في عالم تكنولوجيا المعلومات بسبب
قدرتها على تاليف الخطب وروايه القصص في
ثواني معدوده وبدقه بالغه اعتمادا على
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن هذه المنصه التي تم
تغذيتها بكميات ضخمه من البيانات ليست
مثيره للاعجاب فقط وانما للشكوك ايضا حيث
اشار علماء وخبراء تكنولوجيا المعلومات
الى اربع ثغرات اساسيه في نظام تشارت جي
تي
اولها امكانيه التلاعب في حيث يعتمد نظام
تشاد
على مجموعه واسعه للغايه من التطبيقات اما
الثغره الثانيه فتتمثل في صعوبه تتبع
مصادر المعلومات او المحتوى في النظام
المشكله الثالثه تتمثل في في المتعلقه
بحمايه الخصوصيه حيث تظل المخاوف بشان
تامين البيانات وحمايتها في كل تقنيه
جديده اما المشكله الرابعه فاتت تمثل في
ان نظام المنصه ما زال غير ناضج وفي مرحله
التطور
خاصه بعض الخبراء عددا من المهمات
والوظائف الاكثر عرضه للزواج وتوليها من
قبل ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعيه الاخرى على
المدى القريب نتعرف على ابرزها
الذكاء الاصطناعي يهدد بعض الوظائف
الوظائف التقنيه مثل البرمجه وتطوير
التطبيقات وتحليل البيانات
وظائف الاعلام مثل انشاء المحتوى والكتابه
الفنيه والصحافه
الوظائف القانونيه مثل مساعد قانوني
الوظائف التسويقيه مثل باحث في التسويق
والاعلانات
الوظائف الماليه مثل المستشار المالي
والمحلل المالي الوظائف التعليميه مثل
المعلمون
معنى من دبي انس المرعي المختص في الشؤون
المعلوماتيه والتقنيه انس اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه بدايه
فيما يختلف عن غيره من ادوات الذكاء
الاصطناعي خاصه المتعلقه بالتحرير والبحث
مساء الخير وصباح الخير
يختلف بشكل كبير عن جوجل مبدئيا وعن سيري
او اليكسا من امازون
ومنافسيه من تطبيقات الذكاء الصناعي
خليني اذكرها سريعا قد او خليني ابدا في
في القول بانه كان جي بي تي من وجهه نظري
الشخصيه هو كان الانجح تسويقيا والاوسع
انتشارا بشكل
فظيع خلينا نقول مايكروسوفت لديها منافس
جوجل لديها منافس فيسبوك لديها منافس اي
بي ام لديها منافس وامازون لديها منافس
لايجاد جي بي تي لو سالت الانترنت او تشات
جي بي تي عن هاي
الاختلافات راح يجاوبنا ويقول لك بانه لكل
منصه مميزات وحسنات تختلف حسب حاجتي انا
ولكن الظاهر اليوم الكبير انه اكتسح السوق
للمستخدم النهائي
كاناس عاديين بينما التطبيقات الاخرى كان
لها نصيب عند البزنس اكثر
هناك اثار اخلاقيه وعلميه الان
يعني الاساتذه في الجامعات وفي المدارس
يعني يتخوفون من الغش يعني الطلبه
بامكانهم اعداد بحوث كامله او اوراق بحثيه
كامله من خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي خاصه
الى اي حد برايك علينا ان نقلق من
وهل يمكن ان يكون مفيدا ام هو يعني
سيغير مفهوم البحث
هو سلاح ذو حدين بالطبع صهيب وازيدك من
الشعر
قبل اسبوعين نجح في امتحان شهاده الام بي
اي اللي هي ماجستير اداره الاعمال نقول عن
امتحان مطول جدا
هذا الموضوع
هل يعني هذا خطر على الجامعات يعني وعلى
اصلا مصداقيه
رسائل الماجستير او يعني بقيه البحوث حتى
في الدراسه يعني بالنسبه للسنوات الجامعيه
وهناك جامعات على العموم بدات تتخذ
اجراءات وهناك تقنيات للتحقق اذا كانت
البحوث مثلا
تستخدم فيها الذكاء الاصطناعي ام لا
مئه بالمئه بس بدي بدي يعني نروح تقريبا
عشرين سنه لوراء او اكثر شوي عندما
ظهر جوجل وظهرت صح الكل كان متخوف نعم كنا
صغار السن يمكن شوي ما كنا مثل اليوم لكن
كان الكل متخوف من انه ماذا يحصل للكتاب
ماذا سيحصل للكتاب ماذا سيحصل للمعلومات
اليوم
وغيره من الادوات هي مجرد اداء الاداه اي
انسان ممكن يستخدمها هي سلاح ذو حدين انا
من وجهه نظري بشوف انه
الثغرات التي قيل ان جي بي تي يعاني منها
ما رايك فيها هل يعني تؤثر على مستقبله ام
لا
بامكان المطورين يعني ان يسدوا هذه
الثغرات
منصه ثانيه صهيب تشاد جي بي تي قد يعاني
من بعض الثغرات ولكن هي ثغرات اخلاقيه شوي
رايحه باتجاه الثغرات الاخلاقيه اكثر من
انا امنيه لانه
غير متصل بشكل رئيسي بالانترنت مثل
سيرفرات جوجل وخوادم جوجل بما معنى انه
جوجل وغيره هو مفهرس لهذه المواقع
وبالتالي هو عرفه للاختراق بينما تشاد جي
بي تي هو بنك للمعلومات
واختراقه اصعب بكثير من اختراق شبكات
الانترنت والمواقع التي تعتمد على الخوادم
والانترنت بشكل رئيسي شكرا جزيلا لك انس
المرعي المختص في الشؤون المعلومات من دبي
[موسيقى]
في اول تعليق مفصل لها منذ اجبارها على
الخروج من دون رئيسه وزراء بريطانيا
السابقه تؤكد انه لم يتم منحها فرصه
حقيقيه لتنفيذ جدول اعمالها الخاص بخفض
الضرائب من قبل حزبها ومن قبل مؤسسه
اقتصاديه ذات نفوس وبينما اقرت بانها لم
تكن منزهه من الخطا على الطريقه التي
تفككت بها الميزانيه المصغره لوزير
الخزانه الا انها ما زالت تعتقد ان نهجها
بشان قياده النمو كان هو الصحيح
هذه التصريحات تاتي في ظل ازمه اضرابات
غير مسبوقه منذ عشر سنوات وجهه حكومه
النقابات العماليه دخلت في تحدي مع
الحكومه عبر الاضرابات اما سائقوا
الحافلات فباتوا يواجهون كل من الحكومه
والاتحاد الذي يمثلهم والشركه التي يعملون
فيها في اضرابهم ويصف بعض هؤلاء الامر
بالحرب على ثلاث جبهات لان النقابه اتفقت
مع الحكومه والمشغل على عرض لتحسين اجورهم
ولكن يبدو انه لم يكن مقنعا بالنسبه
للكثير
اخبار الساعه الرياضيه لليانتا النوري
مساء الخير
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك اهلا بكم مشاهدينا خسر مانشستر
سيتي على ملعبي مضيفي توتنهام الرابعه على
التوالي في الدوري الانجليزي وانتهت قمه
مباريات الجوله الحاديه والعشرين بهدف من
دون مقابل سجله هاري كين الذي اصبح ثالث
لاعب يسجل 200 هدف في الدوري بعد اعلى شرر
روني وايضا الهداف التاريخي لفريقه
توتنهام تجمد الرصيد سيتي عند النقطه
الخامسه والاربعين بفرق خمس نقاط عن
ارسنال متصدر بينما اصبح توتنهام بفرق
نقطه عن يوكاسل الربح
في اسبانيا سقط ريال مدريد حمل اللقب بهدف
من دون مقابل امام ريال مايوركا في
مباراته الاخيره قبل المشاركه في كاس
العالم للانديه سجل ناتشو مدافع ريال هدفا
المباراه الوحيد بالخطا في مرمى فريقه
بينما اهدر ماركو ركله جزاء للريال لتجمد
الرصيد الفريق الذي فاز مره واحده في ثلاث
جولات ليتجمد عند 45 نقطه في المركز
الثاني
جهه اخرى انضم البلجيكي
الى قائمه اصابات ريال مدريد قبل توجه
الفريق الى الموديل للانديه في المغرب
مدريد سيخسر ايضا خدمات فيرلاند مندي
ومليتاو كما اعلن عن غياب كريم بنزيما
في ايطاليا وصل نابولي الابتعاد بصداره
الدوري عبر الفوز على
بثلاثه اهداف من دون مقابل فجار الحاديه
والعشرين تقدم خفيتشا كافا
بهدف لنا من ضربه جزاء وسجل المتالق
فيكتور اوسيمين الهدفين الثاني والثالث
لنابلي الفوز هو الخامس على التوالي لنا
منذ تعرض تعرضه لهزيمته الاولى هذا الموسم
على ملعب انتر ميلان نابلي رفع رصيده الى
56 نقطه في مسيرته نحو اللقب الثالث
والاول منذ عام 90
هدفه الاول منذ طعمه من مرض السرطان وجاء
في انتصار برشا دورتموند خمسه اهداف مقابل
هدف على الجوله التاسع عشر من الدوري
الالماني دورتم تقدم في الدقيقه السادسه
والعشرين بهدف من نقل شلاتربك وادرك
فرايبك تعادل عبر لوكس الى ان دورتموند
استعاد التفوقه بهدف كريم قديمي قبل ان
يسجل سيباستيان هولر هدفه الاول منذ تع
فيه من المرض ورفع تفوق دورتموند الى
ثلاثه اهداف لهدف فيما حمل الرابع الاهداف
اسمها
الذي رفع رصيده الى 37 نقطه في المركز
الثالث وظل فرايبورد في المركز السادس
صاحبته اثر فوزه على مايندز بهدفين مقابل
هدف في الجوله التاسعه عشره من البطوله
تقدم اصحاب الارض في الدقيقه الثانيه
والثلاثين بهدف كيفن بيرنز وعادل ضيوف
النتيجه في الدقيقه الثامنه والسبعين من
ركله جزاء نفذها ماركوس انفارستن واستعادت
جوردن تفوق يونيون برلين في الدقيقه
الرابعه والثمانين برلين جمعه 39 نقطه
ليواصل مطارده بايرن ميونخ الذي استعاد
الصداره بفارق نقطه واحده
حقق اياكس فوزا كبيرا بخمسه اهداف من دون
رد على مضيفه غامبورد ضمن منافسات الدوري
الهولندي افتتح القائد دستانتاداش التسجيل
قبل ان يتقاسم ستيفن
هدف الاربعه الاخرى واقل فريق المدرب جوني
هتنجان الفارق مع متصدر الدوري فاينرد الى
ثلاث نقاط بعدما رفع رصيده الى اربعين
نقطه
وكان المتصدر فاين قد تعادل امام وظيفي
بهدفين لمثلهما وظل صاحب الارض متاخرا في
النتيجه حتى الضاد دقائق من الوقت بدل
الضائع من عمر اللقاء قبل ان يتمكن من
تعديل النتيجه يجب ان نرى الان الاهداف
اصبح بثلاثه واربعين نقطه في الصداره بفرق
نقطتين عن الكمر الثاني وثلاث نقاط عن
اياكس الثالث
الى البرتغال حيث اعزز بنفيكا صدرته
للدوري بعد فوزه الكبير على ضيفه كذافيه
بثلاثه اهداف من دون مقابل في جوله التاسع
عشر جواو ماريو سجل الهدفين الاول والثاني
لينتظر الكسندر للدقيقه الحاديه والسبعين
لمضيفه الهدف الثالث الذي رفع الرصيد
بنفيكا الى خمسين نقطه متقدما ب 8 نقاط عن
مطارده بورتو بينما بقي كازابيا على 30
نقطه
في الارجنتين قضى بابلو في غيتي فريقه
للانتصار بهدفين مقابل هدف على
بمدينه قرطبه احرز بابلو فيكيتي هدف
السابق لصاحب الارض في الدقيقه الثامنه
والثلاثين ليعود في الدقيقه السابعه
والستين ويضيف الهدف الثاني وسجل اجناسيو
فرنانديز هدف ريفر بليت الوحيد يرفع
رصيده الى اربع نقاط وبقي روفر بليت عند
ثلاث نقاط
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
اليك صهيب
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك ليليان مستويات قياسيه للحراره
المتدنيه وطقس شديد البروده مصحوب برياح
قويه يجتاح شمال شرقي الولايات المتحده
حيث سجلت منطقته
فيها درجه الحراره لاقل من 50 درجه مئويه
تحت الصفر ووصلت درجه حراره الهواء في
الذروه الى ما دون 44 درجه مئويه تحت
الصفر مع رياح تقترب سرعتها من 160 كلم في
الساعه حسب ما ذكر مرصد
فيما افاد ممثل ادعاء مقاطعه
في بيان بان الرياح العاديه اسقطت شجره
على سياره في ساوث ويك في الولايه ما ادى
الى تحطيمها ومقتل رضيع هذا وامرت حاكمه
ولايه مصاص
محطه السكك الحديديه الرئيسيه في مدينه
بوسطن مفتوحه طوال الليل لتكون بمثابه
ماوى للطوارئ ولا سيما للمشردين للتدفئه
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
اوكرانيا تتوقع هجوم الروسيا هذا الشهر
وتتعهد بعدم ضرب الاراضي الروسيه
بالصواريخ بعيده المدى
في مرمى نيران الجمهوريين بسبب المنطاد
الصيني وفي كين تتخذ خطوه استباقيه وتقيل
مدير هيئه الارصاد
العربيه في معسكر النسائي للبشمركه تعرض
تعرض شهادات حصريه من متظاهرات هربنا من
التعذيب في ايران
الكشف عن اربع ثغرات اساسيه في برنامج
الذي يستخدم تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]